avoir une encore indécis ce jour neuf de
la campagne électorale où la d'être au
bon endroit au bon moment
une rare unanimité en campagne pour
appuyer lui pea le chemin de la campagne
électorale ce matin c'est le chemin des
agriculteurs du québec
l'important dans cette journée cruciale
c'est faire front commun phare francs
comme trois chefs sur quatre françois
legault lui est à 370 km de là à vol
d'oiseau très content d'être ici à
saguenay
est-ce que vous ne rompez paul le
message d'une est limité vous écoutez
trop jean françois lisée
monsieur legault déçoit moi j'étais
sensé est à baie comeau j'ai changé mon
horaire pour est ici et manon massé
aussi
moi je n'ai pas hésité un instant à être
là et je dois être à valdes à dans
quelques minutes
et ce n'est qu'à 20 heures 38 hier soir
que les libéraux ont annoncé leur
participation
côté de l'acaa qu'ils ont l'impression
vous avez kg en quelque sorte leur
serait donc pas capable de prendre
lui-même une décision c'est pas la
journée faire des petites politique la
petite politique d' acte politique
c'est un unanime unanime quelques
minutes
et puis à propos d'une éventuelle brèche
dans la gestion de l'offre
monsieur lisez lui a déjà dit qu'il a
trouvé acceptable je le jure acceptable
seulement si les producteurs les
transformateurs laitiers l'ex suis déçu
que monsieur couillard ne soit pas à la
hauteur de l'occasion
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal
[Musique]